yeah welcome to this video I'll play a
couple of games on icc I start with
three minute and i hope i get steady
flow of opponents it's not so easy
sometimes all right again we got a Slav
exchange and he's playing with a six
yeah try to prevent his bishop at five
move and tell ya this is some simular to
the loop yet game Cromley go wrong in ya
black ass um of course Hallie solid as
usual ok maybe when we can play Knight
h5 now ok I want to get an i2c 554 take
here Knight a5 got tonight on my
discoveries ok better take here yeah
this is so less than nothing probably
yeah cannot do much besides our
exchanging more yeah maybe for those
games on video I should play some some
other line it's a it's a bit boring okay
I'm not my doubts do then trying to
exchange all the CFL yeah unfortunately
he's even got he got this move yeah this
is so annoying this piece that's some
way to improve the position not easy now
maybe I can get the 91 so first also not
great they want to do is play rook c3 if
possible maybe then trying to kick the
night well pretty pretty awful position
sure what's happening i've got this
think i'm i'm still following the
broadcast te dijo get rid of this it's
really annoying this flashes okay i want
to get rid of this this night it's
really a really annoying peace with them
but they're coming on see for every time
ok so the worst should be over I hope
night to to see 5 would be an a way to
make progress may be here not be five if
he pushes but I can exchange now and the
night shouldn't be too bad in the
structure maybe can play before and then
I need to exchange on see for myself
yeah not too great it's not too great
time warning wow wow um if I take on c4
know and yeah it's got beep
you have the pawns probably promote if i
take it takes on c4d seafoam and before
take tank yeah probably i can apply this
okay yeah only chance the sun to play
for some perpetual so yeah this looks
like a perpetual maybe I've got it yeah
this is perpetual check so sorry lucky
to get this in ja ja ja wrong wrong yeah
bad game okay let's hope it will get
better this can of exchange this love is
obviously not the way to go there are
some ways to get a little bit of
something but here just I just got
nothing
yeah no opponent come on me too yeah get
rid of this broadcast yeah the broadcast
is some covering the country running
Grand Prix tournament inning in London
with them couple of top players in them
on like oh my no gree shook Nakamura and
so on the usual suspects it doesn't have
aronian Kramnik or Carlton get started
lots of top players oops okay we got a
game at Nimes Oh with these three
currently trying to practice this
variation a little yeah the structure
similar to the Queens gambit exchange
but of course some of the differences
that I don't have from the bishop out of
the pawn chain so how to continue here
not quite sure I'm not used to these
positions really
okay at least that it opens up now yeah
I'm not used to the same these positions
and really am would need a bit more time
to figure out how to play but ok I only
get three minutes this doesn't look too
bad i'm somewhat better developed and
the position is opening up a lot here oh
the surprises me he gives me the Bishop
Bishop c4 Queen takes Bishop f60 it
doesn't really lead to anything but I
can go here right I can go here
threatening Bishop f6 young Queen h4
maybe Quinn d3 good age 5 yahoo it's not
not so great probably wasn't the best
continuation still have no problem for
me but the clock laga should should have
something serious the servants should be
okay for black I try rookie 3g three I
don't want to exchange Queens with the
same attacking possibilities but he's
got Bishop t5 also now yeah probably
this is just nothing hmm
maybe maybe it can go rook to g4 so this
is this kind of stuff try it for up
chiffon and I'm also taking a fall
that's not the most important porn ever
but maybe i can i can simply take it
okay he allows this i'm not sure i think
i would have rather given away the polar
form than to allow this here this looks
a bit dangerous I have some ideas Quinn
g5 to h6 end and stuff like that okay hi
money going to h6 is coming let's check
quickly that I know don't think this
should be fine look to g4 may be
threatening whoops g6 now yeah it's not
I'll take it it's made on HH me yeah I
got some initiative with this nice
diagonal I think you should have simply
given this given this pawn I mean I
don't know in this position just um
pm dunno here here's some sam move like
a no-look rookie 6 rookie 6 g 6 and
simply I'm ignore this threat on a phone
shouldn't be too too dangerous can have
a look at this feel let's say let's say
this one I've got ruka ATM okay because
this is not possible and maybe some
other move then what about this and I
can take it and play okay here can it's
not it's not so easy this is some
slightly slightly annoying position
alright a new game um I go e form let's
mix it up don't let's see what happens
you have the dragon I don't know the
sharp lines and the dragon so I'd play
em more strategical kind of line play
Bishop f1 Maya Bishop g5 stuff like that
similar to UM c-45 and in the English
opening yeah 97 I'm not quite sure about
this move maybe wants to go to c5 but
ok now the special bond g5 is a bit of a
problem k 2 1 wanting to play perform
game always attacking ok should I go
Knight d4 even why not 95 is a move I
want to play uh-huh he wants to play
Knight c4 really really hard ok i still
i can i can play this young so let's um
consolidate this a bit yeah it's a bit
dumb confusing of those nights in the
center here um ok is increasing pressure
here on d5 hmm yeah I don't want to take
on b6 not sure maybe I need to yeah
probably
mmm not sure that I have anything better
already came let's try to exchange the
bishop after all this looks like a
strong piece but you can always just
play a bishop h8 everyone's alright so
maybe get the Queen near the Kings side
go into each form something like this
okay he wants to use the fifth-ranked so
interesting idea the IT threatened
snider three check ok I think I need to
move the Queen not much choice yeah time
one ok let's protect PB to this way yeah
okay this route I'm not quite sure that
really am leads to anything don't don't
mind this moves that I get now with the
temple re 555 mmm this was silly yeah
completely unnecessary what did I do
that yeah I could have first them taking
care about about the Sun issue on the
diagonal again now I can only hope to to
get some attack attack going here ok
let's take it
can you create at least threatening
checkmate in one well so I've got F 60
bit of something but if you place yeah
what exactly am i doing if you place the
smooth I can play here Queen takes Queen
ahead grab the bishop yeah alright so
what's still very tricky and i'm down to
14 seconds now I where we can just
exchange and try to try to win this end
game position seems okay really okay
yeah of course I will never lose this
position chess wise but time wise black
forfeits on time mmm so strange they got
very very slow at at some point um yeah
well okay the position here is probably
even winning for me but um okay no time
no time at all yeah is it winning hand
hard to tell
of course the way it went it wasn't but
ok let's a king of three probably wins
here yeah I guess so yeah alright it's a
three minute game what can you do game
starting next one Goff town I think this
is a total player I am young ok so let's
go for a Sicilian made a video on the
Sicilian just yesterday has an idol so
let's play it don't have really good
knowledge but maybe leads to some fun
game aha very Queenie to hold the am
looking for quick long castle and then
f45 this kind of stuff hmm interesting
ok threatening nights is six winning the
Queen some need to take about 96 and it
looks looks tricky ok and yeah looks
fairly dangerous I'm not quite sure how
to UM how to play here of course at some
point I need to use this Bishop not
quite sure I can play 6am I'm got the
suspicion that down he might go hope you
should h3 and simply secondly six with
with some peace yeah
okay detective form yeah if I go e6 now
he probably will sacrifice it's got the
Queen h5 also maybe I'm shut down take
away queen age five and now is six if
you sacrifice now it's still dangerous
but I don't think it should win outright
yeah FYI 5am this is of course possible
maybe this irritates them a bit okay
yeah how to how to play I can never play
a five because of night f5 so long maybe
I should even bring the bishop back to
the seven yeah but neither can maybe I
can get something on g5 now Quincy five
also coming right still fairly dangerous
we can take on on l7m
hey I can always take on f7 if I grew up
here yeah store what else after what
else should I do uh-huh the media takes
me time Niall maybe it's it's even
better yeah okay not much that I can do
maybe I can somehow survive this it
looks looks lost frankly oh I simply
overlooked that if you're saying oh oops
okay yeah okay everything's okay yeah
this is what I said yesterday in the
video if you play the night off and you
don't exactly know what to do against
Bishop g5 then yeah you are out for
trouble yeah I don't know doesn't look
too bad but yeah this is really already
very tricky I don't have any play don't
have any play on the queenside and this
is a bad piece on f eight and so on it's
not great yeah it certainly not lost or
anything but very difficult to play the
position first couple of news weather
maybe I mean I don't think this this is
this is too bad game the time okay let's
go koo fraud say QVC from Germany let's
play the two nights tango Black Knights
tango I haven't played this for ages
it's not so bad
play this some number of times even in
tournament chess classical time control
long-term results some were quite okay
black now goes into a king's indian
setup and inserts yes sorry it's the g3
line of the Kings Indian with a 3 and e
6 as extra moves try to play 4 p-5 am so
very strange position if you are not
used to this this kind of opening maybe
I can exchange one pair of nodes if you
take such egg with the night ok insults
ok yeah yeah this are like now I can I
control this diagonal and can probably
exchange them at some point I'm not sure
about nine different maybe I can just go
here this looks like a decent movie ok
it's chris please planning for 92 let
some clarify this position yeah now I've
got a slide on space disadvantage but i
have from pretty good pieces I've got no
one long-term bad piece no bad bishop or
anything
of course he's got the a file or he will
will get the a phone what I'd like to do
is get him to move the F pause that I
can play 94 again this is why I'm
playing these moves maybe this is some a
bit too HD but like to do something
active okay let's let's go for this yeah
this is so very nice structure okay
immediately tries to use them this shaky
night position but is it too awful I
mean Queen f7 h5 can I do that hmm I try
it shouldn't be too bad on on on h5 now
maybe I've got rupee eight coming this
should be a playable position I mean
shouldn't be too awful okay oh this is
nice now I can take with the porn right
okay click here yeah he's gotta cut the
bed bishop
rucca 82 f 3 would be would be nice time
morning I can go here to check out an
age 70 it's no big deal I didn't see
this move hmm this is some the spoon
this is not so great don't see how to
make any progress here or i can go here
so maybe a bit risky with the time but
position is not bad guy is not playing
too quickly this is cell phone yeah but
it's a draw oops gave me this pawn Chet
white reason
yeah yeahs gave me the gist she just
gave me to be porn it was a draw but
with with this with this time control
what can you do nyt started next game
against him women Grandmaster here
nautic check the name after sis italia
shoe cover she's really a she's a major
grandmaster also shouldn't she be
rooting for I like Sal agree shock we
sure get some suka vas husband she's
playing on the ICC wall while the
husband discerning earning the money are
pitted alright so we got some ditalion
game him and while i was chatting away m
I'm not sure if I got into a really good
position here some something i usually
play from from black site of course all
right i don't want one day 53 softening
up them the queenside young there should
be six coming should I play night h4
maybe a night eh for threatening like g6
also and here he now needs hehe no she
now needs to take out or allow me to to
to keep the night of course that's
counter play on them on d3
maybe this one threatening on on h6 now
and complicated position yeah I cannot
move the night this is annoying to see
for may be renewing the threat yeah but
maybe she can take now a tape with the
pawn that's maybe if also mmm but it's a
dangerous don't know okay just just just
just take it yeah of course yeah she can
play 94 now i just thought I castle and
that it doesn't look too bad I hope so
should I drop back the bishop yeah
probably looks nice keeps a 5 protected
and t3 sm prevented also but I can play
maybe Bishop f4 next we should be for
controlling a five okay mmm yeah why
should the Queen go I don't see it how
to continue but this shouldn't be too
bad let's attack this porn on c7
highwire just go rook t2 t1 this is an
idea keep it simple on 95 I can play f
6m okay not sure the f6 really / leads
to something rate but I can also just
move the bishop on 95 it's not they're
not terrible all right yeah it's
complicated position but 95 should be a
threat now 95 yeah but yeah it's no no
threat here taketake mid-70s hanging I
don't need to play of six immediately it
can be an idea but I don't need to play
it I know this booth should be nice hmm
yeah yeah end game with the bishop town
yeah this is some interesting endgame I
hope that just gave this away the
problem is simply the time we most
likely i won't and Noelle she could have
checked also yeah i would note i'm glad
for it yeah this is the problem with
three minutes yes really this is why i
would love to play like 21 or something
or 31 so that I ok I would have lost the
game here but would be deserving after
blundering c2 c3 here I'm not sure about
about others i think i should be better
really but maybe I'm overestimating this
position I of course I must take on d7
and take on d7 take on c3 with the
bishop yup like a son like a solid and
solid though it's nothing nothing stare
alone yeah all right yeah next game
let's just play one more for this
session yeah yeah she so she's a male
grandmaster also she's got them the yeah
the real Brent master tittle-tattle also
but she doesn't have a tienda in the
name never bothered to learn to update
this ok let's hope for for game iam
game started okay I Grove awesome yeah
let's play something else what I don't
play usually d 6 grand master from
Armenia yeah but not one of the Olympic
champions and fortunately you decided on
the the tradeline here the some Queen
exchange is some of course an option for
wide but it shouldn't down be too scary
for black white um usually retains a
small advantage but it's nothing
dramatic usually from what I know I
don't play this opening on a regular
basis mm-hmm okay it tries to get
Nigeria 95 in
hmm yeah the Sun is not very pleasant
yeah me too yeah try to read offend this
guy's got done this really pesky night
on on f5 how to get rid of this piece
not quite sure night c5 i canna that you
can trade one pair of rooks they are
probably I should do that hmm yeah this
is some prime example of some of simple
simple chess but effective hmm yeah lets
some quite difficult to protect the f6
pawn can I get some counter play on f5
maybe like g3 rook g5 yeah but can take
here just so so awful so I Scott them is
coming out of 7
hmm yes he's winning a couple of pawns
IAM not sure maybe maybe I have still
some chances to fight i get f 2 and then
I have some counterplay III ii 43 and so
on aha so I could I could actually take
the H porn right let's do this the f
porn is dangerous but I think I always
have from time warning you to I need
money to do this first to prevent the F
porn from moving yeah I'm is getting all
this I need to edit eh porn it's um it's
probably lost yeah i'm not claiming that
this is great iam but I can back install
fight a bit
check ID observe sound coming samba
should be some okay check that's no
trick out there is simply no trick check
check yeah should I resign or play on
time I will probably win on time if I
want it's really slow oh this is silly
white for whoop some time yeah whatever
II wanted to resign evening but erm yeah
this is silly chess yung you ok I can
resign i try to even but it hit hit the
wrong button yeah it's a bit stupid that
they don't offer any increment times it
costs you then would simply don't have
this kind of stupid results even if i
went on time it doesn't doesn't really
have satisfied all right yeah thanks for
watching the thing there was some quite
interesting games than them um yeah talk
to you soon flew videos